مشاهدينا الكرام هكذا ظهرت المناطق التي
تضررت بفعل الزلزال اليوم المناطق الصفراء
كما نشاهد المناطق البرتقاليه هي مركز
الزرزال وتوسعت دائره الضرر لتصل الى
المناطق الخضراء والمناطق الزرقاء مناطق
شعور بالزلزال ننتقل اكثر لنقترب من هذه
الخريطه هذا هو كان مركز الزلزال اليوم
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه كهرمان مره
كانت هي مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب هذه
المنطقه هذا هذا المركز يتصل من كهرمان
مراش الى تقريبا اطراف مدينه حلب وهذه
المسافه تصل تقريبا الى حوالي 155 كيلو
متر كانت نصف قطر دائره هذا الزلزال لتكون
هذه هي الدائره التي ضربها الزلزال هذا
اليوم في المنطقه الجنوبيه المنطقه
الجنوبيه كانت اكثر المناطق تضررا بفعل
اكثر من عامل اولا الكثافه السكانيه في
المناطق الجنوبيه من تركيا وايضا الازمه
الانسانيه التي يعيشها اللاجئون السوريون
في مناطق الشماليه من الشماليه الغربيه من
سوريا اذا انتقلنا الى الخريطه سوريا
تحديدا وهي الازمه التي يعيشها السوريون
الان هذه المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
المعارضه السوريه من جرابلس الى الريف
الشمالي من حلب اعزاز طبعا داخله في تلك
المنطقه وادلب وصولا الى هذه الاطراف هذه
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات او
المعارضه السوريه وبالتالي هذه المناطق
كانت خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه محط
الضربات العنيفه للطيران الحربي السوري في
استهداف مناطق المعارضه في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه وبالتالي كل المناطق
المدنيه والبنيه التحتيه في هذه المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا كانت مناطق
بطبيعه الحال متضرره فجاء الزلزال ليزيد
هذه الاضرار هذا ما يفسر الاعداد الكبيره
من القتلى والضحايا في المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه من الاراضي السوريه طبعا كما
ذكرنا فقد كانت دائره الزلزال الاولى
حوالي 150 كم من كهرمان ميراج الى الشمال
السوري ولكن دائره الزلزال الشعوري وصلت
الى حوالي 900 كيلو اي ان هناك مناطق في
مصر الاسكندريه في هناك كان هناك شعور
بينزلزال وان كانت هذه الضربات او الهزات
الارتداديه خفيفه في تلك المناطق ولكن قوه
الزلزال وصلت الى حوالي 900 كيلو متر كما
ذكرنا من المنطقه الجنوبيه تكون هذه هي
المناطق التي غطاها الزلزال هذه المناطق
التي غطاها الزلزال بشكل اساسي دائره
الخضراء هي المنطقه الرئيسيه للضربات
الزلزاليه وصلت الى 7.9 على مقياس ريختر
ولكن الشعور بالزلزال وصل الى 900 كيلو
متر بقي ان نشير الى مقياس ريختر بشكل
سريع هذا هو مقياس ريختر عندما تكون
على درجه على مقياس ريخطر عندما تكون
الدرجه رقم واحد او من صفر الى واحد فهذا
زلزال يعتبر مجهري وهو الزلزال الذي لا
يشعر به احد ولكن المؤشرات او الرادارات
تلتقط هذا الزلزال الزلزال الطفيف
والزلزال الخفيف هو الذي يشعر به الناس
بشكل خفيف جدا الزلزال المعتدل يشعر به
الناس بشكل اقوى الزلزال القوي هو بعض
الزلازل المدمره وعندما نشاهد الزلزال
الكبير وهو الزلزال الذي حصل اليوم في
تركيا كان من نوع الزلزال الكبير هو اكثر
من سبع درجات من سبعه الى ثمان من سبعه
الى سبعه فاصله تسعه اي ان الزلزال الذي
حصل اليوم اذا اكدت المعلومه بانه 7.9 على
مقياس هذا يعني انه على بعد يعني موعد
بسيط جدا من الدخول في
الزلزال العظيم وهو الزلزال المدمر الذي
يعتبر اعلى معايير الزلازل طبعا عندما
نتحدث على مقياس سر اختر عن درجه الى درجه
هذا لا يعني ان الدرجه الثانيه تساوي ضعف
الدرجه الاولى لما الدرجه الثانيه تساوي
عشر اضعاف الدرجه الاولى وهذا هو مال الذي
نشاهده على طرف الشاشه من هنا حيث ان
الدرجه الاولى تساوي الدرجه الثانيه تساوي
عشر اضعاف الدرجه الاولى والدرجه الثالثه
تساوي ثلاثه اعشار في الاضعاف من الدرجه
الاولى وبالتالي كل الانتقال من درجات
ريختر يعني انتقال في عشر اضعاف عن الدرجه
التي تسبقها وتوسع بطبيعه الحال في
الدائره الزلزاليه هذا الذي يفسر السقوط
الكبير
للضحايا في هذه المنطقه صحيح ان هذا
الاعداد لم تكن كبيره نتحدث الان عن اكثر
من الف تقريبا في تركيا وبدا مئات في
سوريا ولكن الاعداد كبيره اذا ما قرن في
الزلازل الماضيه اعنف زلزال كان في تركيا
كان اخر زلزال عنيف كان 1999 حيث سقط 17
الفا من القتلى في تركيا بالزلزال ضرب
منطقه ازمير في هذه
تقريبا
وتفسير بان التفسير في تلك المنطقه في عام
1999 ان المنطقه كانت كثافه سكانيه عاليه
اما في هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن المناطق
الشماليه عمليا هي مناطق شبه خاليه من
السكان وهذا الذي يفسر بانه سقوط الضحايا
كان في المناطق الجنوبيه من التاثير الز